هل ألقت باللوم على إيران في
الضربات الأخيرة على منشآت النفط السعودية
الشهر الماضي والهجوم على
ناقلة نفط إيرانية قبالة سواحل جدة
قبل أيام قليلة هو أن المملكة العربية السعودية ردت
بالضرب بالطبع ، أليس كذلك نحن لا ننخرط في
مثل هذا السلوك؟  ألقى باللوم على إيران
لأن الصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار إيرانية
جعلنا نعلم أن الضربة جاءت
من الشمال وليس من الجنوب ، لقد
طلبنا من الأمم المتحدة تزويد
المحققين بتورط المجتمع في غارة
الناقلة ،
ولا ننخرط في مثل هذا السلوك
إلى جانب ذلك.  تقارير متضاربة
حول هذا الأمر ، تقول شركة النفط الإيرانية الوطنية
إن شيئًا لم يصب شخصًا
آخر شيء أسوأ من الشاحنات يقول الناس أن
هناك تسربًا للنفط ، ويقول آخرون إنه
لا يوجد تسرب للنفط ، لذا فإن القصة
ليست واضحة بعد بشأن هذه المسألة ولكن ما
يمكنني قوله لكم  هل نحن لا ننخرط في مثل هذا
السلوك على الإطلاق ، فهذه ليست الطريقة التي نعمل بها
وليس هذه هي الطريقة التي تعمل بها
في الماضي ، لقد أدانت بوضوح
العملية التركية هناك والتي
حدثت  قيصر أحمر يقاتل هذه القوة الساحقة ،
هل تعتقد أنه كان من الصواب
أن تتخلى الولايات المتحدة عن حلفائها الأكراد
بهذه الطريقة لا أعتقد أنني
سأصفها على هذا النحو ، أعتقد
أن الولايات المتحدة  لا يزال يعمل مع
القوات الكردية في شمال شرق
سوريا وعلى الولايات المتحدة أن
تقرر ما يجب أن تكون عليه أو
لا يجب أن تكون
عليه.  النهج الخاطئ ، هذه
قضية أمريكية ، لكننا نجري
مشاورات وثيقة مع أصدقائنا في
واشنطن ، ونحن نتشاور عن كثب
مع أصدقائنا في
الأشخاص الذين ندعمهم في سوريا ،
ونحن نبحث عن أفضل طريقة
للقيام بذلك.  حاول أن تتفق مع القيادة الكردية
أن الولايات المتحدة  لديه
مسؤولية أخلاقية لحماية الشعب
الذي يقاتل الجانب الذي لم ير ذلك ، لذلك
لن أعلق على ذلك